good afternoon cs109 how are you guys
doing today
oh fantastic that's what I'd love to
hear and um the word of the day is happy
Wednesday I hope you guys are having a
fantastic day I know we're at that like
mid point of the quarter wearing a lots
of things start to get a little bit more
intense and I just appreciate you guys
for doing what you do
and one of the ways of showing that
appreciation is we've got a very fun
class today we're going to learn
something incredibly
useful and also which is expansive it
takes the things that you've started to
learn in cs109 it's going to allow it to
expand to describe more and more
complexities in the world we are going
to be learning about probabilistic
modeling so thinking not just about one
random variable not just about two
random variables but a whole bunch of
random variables being random together
maybe like a real world scenario uh you
will walk out today's class hopefully
having mastered or understood some of
these core techniques for modeling okay
then I also have a little bit of a hook
for you I want to tell you about one
project that I found very interesting
one of the things that I found very
interesting uh especially when I was a
PhD student is that computers were so
bad at understanding beginner
programmers and the mistakes that they
would make so to give you an example
there is this website called code.org
and people write programs using these
very simple block-based languages their
programs are like six lines long
and computers were a total disaster at
looking at those six lines and
understanding what misconceptions the
student has like you look at this this
block of code and be able to say
um what sort of idea the student was
missing
and code.org has a lot of data they have
tens of thousand students
um you know and 37 000 unique solutions
to this five line program they have lots
of History they can have some teachers
helping with this process and yet they
were not able to understand basic
mistakes that student makes
I'm going to jump to the conclusion but
to understand how we got to that
conclusion you'll have to follow along
today's class so the idea that we came
up with was well first can we just use
some pretty basic statistics like count
conditional probabilities of mistakes
given the fact that they have a for Loop
or given the fact that they have an if
statement in the for Loop and basic
statistics didn't get us very far you
might have heard of this exciting thing
called Deep learning we tried a lot of
deep learning on this and if green is
how well humans do and you want to be
high on this chart deep learning wasn't
getting very close at all
but we took some inspiration from this
beautiful project which described a
probabilistic model over all the ways
that humans could write did a hand-drawn
digits or characters so for this
particular character you can create a
whole probabilistic model that describes
the process that somebody goes to write
these characters we took inspiration
from this and we brought to the world of
beginners writing code and we thought
well what if we wrote the probabilistic
model for beginners writing code and we
did and it was a good time and by we I
mostly mean there was a student called
who was a TA for 109 a year ago he wrote
this beautiful generative model and it
was able to outperform humans at the
task of figuring out what bugs a student
had
um
now code is a complicated thing think
about imagining code in the world of
random variables and by code I mean like
the whole production that a student
makes it's a complicated thing there's
lots of moving pieces there you're going
to need something more than just one
random variable you'll need something
more than two random variables stick
around for today's class and we'll talk
about how we could get to many random
variables
but let's build a foundation of where we
left off first
this whole section of cs109
probabilistic models comes down to
talking about random variables being
random together if you can have a deep
understanding of random variables being
rendered together you're in a good place
and the most important fundamental
Concept in this world of probabilistic
models is this idea of a joint
distribution
a joint distribution says if you have
two random variables can you give me a
function an equation a piece of code a
table anything where for any assignment
to all my random variables together you
can tell me the probability of that
joint assignment the joint is the be all
end all if somebody gives you a joint
they've given you complete information
about the probabilistic model
please do enter me if you have questions
or anything confusing about this is a
good time to talk about it
okay I'm seeing some thumbs up which
makes me feel good
um now if the joint was the most
important thing you wanted to have the
most important question was the question
of inference and the question of
inference says You observe some random
variable and your belief about the other
random variables may change we've seen
inference in many forms one inference
task that we saw at the beginning was
you would look at the weight of an
elephant and we would just infer an
updated belief about the gender of the
elephant this is a very simple model
where we imagine the gender of an
elephant was changing the distribution
of their weights so if You observe
weight you could infer a little bit of
signal about what gender they were it's
not a very practical problem no one's
like trying to gender an elephant by
weighing them that's a silly thing to do
but a less silly thing to do is what we
did in last Friday's class wait last
Monday's class in last Monday's class we
did this harder task but much more
meaningful task of doing the visual
Acuity inference
and just a second while the HDMI catches
up
in the elephant task you are inferring a
Bernoulli It could only take on two
values so you only had to do one base
theorem in order to update your belief
but on Monday's class we inferred a
random variable which wasn't Bernoulli
in fact it was a random variable that
was represented using a dictionary that
took on way more than two variable
values it could take up a hundred values
and when you did inference you had to
update your belief that the random
variable took on any of those random
variables so you didn't just need one
Bayes theorem you needed a whole for
Loop of Bayes theorem
so that was the big upgrade that we did
last Monday
uh and also I just want to point out
quickly that
um
in Monday's class we did this really
cool computer science thing where we
represented this random variable using a
dictionary
and that dictionary could map different
assignments the random variable to the
corresponding probability so you can
think of the whole dictionary as the
random variable and a single look or
like you know a key would be like the
little a and a lookup would give you a
probability and for those of you guys
who are more used to computer science
maybe this is a nice little metaphor for
random variables yes
the reason why we didn't use Bernoulli
um
in the second example is because we
didn't know that there's this like a 100
chance zero percent chance is a girl or
a boy if you had to have a function to
describe hearing and not hearing is that
oh yeah going back to the first example
the elephant one so in this world
you would observe weight which is a very
continuous thing but the thing we're
inferring was the gender of an elephant
and that's Bernoulli because it could
only take on two values
I mean what a heteronormative way of
looking at elephants but you know that's
what we did but it was Bernoulli because
in our world of gender there was only
two values
oh and for this visual Acuity you mean
so seeing or not seeing ah no no there's
way more detail to seeing like some
people can see 2020 so like you can see
without glasses at 20 feet healthy
vision and my vision in my left eye is
2100 which means like five times worse
than an average person so there's a
whole shade of gray between you're
seeing like a healthy adult versus you
can't see every anything and there's all
these Shades of Gray and we want to keep
beliefs about all those Shades of Gray
in fact in order to say how well
somebody can see you really do need to
do that you need to keep track of all
the nuance
random variables and beliefs oh my God
you can express yourself so much better
once you master this idea it is such a
powerful language that the whole world
doesn't seem to speak but now you guys
will now know how to speak okay so this
was our big upgrade going from inferring
a Bernoulli random variable to one which
could take on a hundred different values
and that required us to do base theorem
100 times but we had computers so it was
kind of fun
a number of dictionary I've mentioned
this a little bit and then I wanted to
point out two things you know what are
these terms this term was your prior
this term was How likely was an
observation given the true state of
ability to see which was a knowable
thing and based on these two knowable
things we were calculating this hard to
know thing the updated posterior of
ability to seize inference
now this was kind of crazy
when you look at code for people who do
Bayes theorem on random variables that
can take on more than two values you
often see code that looks like this you
often see code where you see references
to things like the prior you often see
code that has references to things like
the likelihood but you hardly ever see
code where they actually in the inner
for Loop where you expect that they
would be calculating the probability of
y equals zero you hardly ever see people
actually calculate probably of y equals
zero and instead what they do is they
calculate all the numerators
and then they normalize them what an
insane thing to do so when you actually
look at code people don't calculate
probably y equals zero instead they
calculate all the numerators and
normalize the reason that that works
if you took probably y equals zero if
you expand it using the law of total
probability it basically says okay we're
going to Loop over a again
and for every possible value of a we're
going to take one of these numerator
Expressions you know the probability
that y equals zero given that a equals
each of the indexes in my for Loop times
the prior of each of my indexes in the
for Loop that's the thing that we're
calculating the numerator every time
through the for Loop
so basically this normalization is a
really really nice neat trick to skip
having to calculate this and then just
realizing that you can calculate all the
numerators
and then if you normalize it it will
implicitly give you all this calculation
for free because normalization will do
the sum over this that gets you this
term and it's going to divide every term
by that sum wow
do I care that you can use the
normalization this really shorter
version of code not so much do I care
that you know Bayes theorem expanded yes
but do I think that you need to know
that these two things are equivalent
absolutely because you're going to see
code that looks like this and when you
see code that looks like this I want you
to know that they're calculating Bayes
theorem properly yes
is basically you're saying that they
work out each of the numerators store it
in an array and then the normalized
function sums up
exactly they were they work just to say
what you said work out each of the
numerators stored in Array and when you
call normalizes it sums over all those
which is that and it divides everything
by that sum whoa so yes exactly you got
it you spot on 100. yay hard Concepts
one of the harder things that we'll do
in this part of cs109
so you guys did all the hardest stuff
now let's do some of the celebratory
stuff and some of the celebratory stuff
is now that you've mastered this hard
Concept in two variables let's start
expanding and just using your knowledge
to be able to do more cool things
learning goals for today I want you guys
to get some perspective on the art form
of Designing probabilistic models and it
is art as much as it is a science of how
you generate models when there's many
random variables I'm going to teach you
about this thing called correlations and
covariances and then I'm going to talk a
little bit about independence in random
variables so we'll have a good
conversation about key Concepts while
learning a new ability
let's talk about how to make a model
there's two ways that you can represent
a model their equivalent
both of them describe the same thing
they describe how many random variables
are random together one way is to write
a Python program I'll get back to this
later
you can write a model through python but
it's easier to express it this way if
you understand the mathematical way of
expressing a model and one of the most
important ways of expressing a model is
this thing called a Bayesian Network
named after our most favorite
mathematician uh Reverend Thomas base
and an abasian Network you're going to
express complicated graphical model or
complicated models of many random
variables and you'll draw them out and
then you'll give some probabilities and
this will specify the whole model it's
going to be great
um I'll talk a little bit more about the
joint distribution
but let's go back to our motivating
example
our motivating example when we first
started talking about probabilistic
models is WebMD and as you call WebMD
has the symptom checker in the symptom
checker you can go and you list your
symptoms and then it tells you your
probability of having different diseases
um and so to do
wow the HDMI is really slow here
so when you go through the symptom
checker
it keeps track of a whole bunch of
random variables some of those random
variables are symptoms that you could
have so you have a whole bunch of
symptoms but you also have some random
variables for causes like actual
diseases you could have so there's
random variables for do you have
diseases there's random variables for
whether or not you have symptoms there's
even random variables for things that
they call you know prior conditions that
can make you more likely to have
diseases like maybe your uh your age or
I'm going to use undergraduate for now
just for a good time
um maybe that could modulate
probabilities as well and you have all
these probabilities and they're working
together and if you want to do proper
inference if you want to tell somebody
the probability of their fever you have
to be able to think about all these
random variables together
the inference question is I tell you an
assignment to some random variables and
your job is update your belief in the
other ones sometimes there's only one
random variable that I care about you
updating
so for example I might tell you I'm
nauseous and I'm tired and I want you to
update your belief that I have the flu
So You observe some things and you
update some belief
uh so here's one inference question I
can say can you give me the probability
that you have the flu given that you're
nauseous and you're tired
but that's not the only inference
question
oh and you know you could use chain rule
you could use a couple different
approaches to solve this
I want to give you a sense that there's
a lot of different inference questions
like for example I could say I have
fever and sore throat and I want you to
update your belief that I have a cold oh
I also want you to update your beliefs
that I am an undergraduate you know like
any random variable if I observe some I
should be able to update my belief in
any other random variable if they're in
a model together
so this is just that other question
written in mathematical notation so c0 I
think is for code that I have another C
yes chest pain so c0 is cold equals one
U equals one given that s equals zero
and fever equals zero
and again you could use chain rule or
you could use Bayes theorem and start to
approach this problem
so if you have
all the joint distribution my claim is
that you can answer any of these
inference problems
but I just want to make sure that we're
on the same page about this if there's
nine random variables and they're all
binary so they can take on zero or one
if you try to represent this joint as a
table you just had a probability table
which said for any assignment of these
random variables I will tell you the
probability how big would that
probability table have to be
talk about what the person next to you
but also with the person next to you see
if you can come up with a question for
what's confusing about this so that we
can talk about it at this point talk
about it with the person next to you
let's come up with an answer
foreign
so that might not have been enough time
but hopefully after a little bit of
thought you got 2 to the power of n
it's exponentially large in the number
of random variables if you have one
random variable you just need to store
two probabilities well actually you can
get away with one probability which is
just the probability of that random
variable being one if you have two
random variable though you end up with a
grid you have the two values that one
random variable could be the two values
that the other random variable could be
and there's four values there
technically you could remove one of them
because you know they sum up to one so
it's still you know 2 squared minus one
if you have three random variables it
will be two to the cubed I often don't
think about this minus one because you
could get away with not representing one
random variable because you know they
all sum to one but two to the three is
normally High I represent if you have
three random variables and if you have n
random variables you're left with two to
the N if you want to store it using a
joint table
we've learned about joint tables it's
clearly not going to cut it here
[Music]
oh yeah so let's say you have
um let's say you only have one random
variable
and that random variable contained on
the value of zero or one
so let's say I tell you the probability
of 1 is 0.8 my claim is that there's
always one value in your whole joint
that you can just infer so here I can
know that this probability is going to
be 0.2 because you know I can just infer
it from that it turns out if you had a
grid
um and let's make these numbers smaller
0.6 0.1 if I make this 0.2
this is six seven eight nine I know that
this one has to be a 0.1 so I could get
away without one that's such a it's such
a detail but I'm glad you asked but you
know long story short never in my life
has this actually really changed
anything it's because 2 to the power of
n is so large minus one is like yeah
whatever
good question
I wanted to motivate why we need models
if you want to be able to do something
like this if you want to write this web
app you couldn't do it using a joint
probability table you'd need a more
sophisticated language for talking about
how random variables can be random
together so shall we learn this more
sophisticated language yes okay
okay uh yeah n could be large this more
sophisticated language takes the name of
Bayesian Networks
and in Bayesian networks you don't have
to give the Complete Joint you can
leverage a hypothesis about how the
world Works to come up with a structure
where you can express the joint with
fewer probabilities it's a beautiful
thing I'm going to tell you this story
of evasion Network through a simpler
WebMD we'll call this the Vaden WebMD
that's only got four random variables
there's fever and tired I think of those
as my symptoms
and flu isn't a symptom flu is a disease
you know how flu is different from fever
flu may be causes a fever
an undergraduate is just going to be
like a pre-existing condition that might
change the probability of seeing you
know some of these symptoms
so the great idea
about a Bayesian Network is we're going
to try and represent this without doing
the exponential combination of all the
probabilities now if there's only four
random variables you might be able to
get away with this exponential
combination you might be able to
represent the 16 2 to the fours equals
16 different assignments of all the four
random variables jointly
but we want to learn a more
sophisticated thing because when I go
beyond four random variables we know
this is going to grow exponentially
so here's what a Stanford flu expert
would do
they would try and describe the process
of these random variables affecting each
other using this thing called causality
now I think I said this lightly I said
flu causes fever
in the real world we think that this
random variable is the reason that this
random variable would be one or zero
even if it's not deterministic it really
changes the probability like knowing flu
is really affecting fever and we think
of that as being the causal Direction
if I tell you fever that would change
your belief that I have a flu like if I
told you I have a fever do you think I'm
more likely to have a flu or not
yeah so it changes your belief but I
don't think it caused the flu I don't
think the fever is what made me have the
flu I think the flu made me have the
fever so probabilities go both ways but
causality we think goes in one direction
do you guys buy this convention I don't
think it's that controversial to say
that a flu causes a fever and that a
fever doesn't cause a flu
someone out there is like but actually
if you have a few of you you're more
likely to get another condition at the
same time but like that's way too
complicated we're going with the simple
version of the world
so what a Stanford flu expert would do
if they wanted to try and represent this
joint probability with many random
variables in a more compressed way they
try and describe causality
flu causes these two symptoms if you
have a flu that's why we think you might
have a fever and that's why we explain
that you are tired
similarly we think that it's the
undergrad nature which is causing you to
be tired
and a flu expert would try and come up
with a reasonable set of causalities
that would explain how these random
variables are causing one another now
the world is a complicated thing there's
lots of ways of telling this some people
talk about like the butterfly effect
where everything is somehow connected
like somehow being undergrad really
might be the thing that's causing you to
have a fever causality is a complicated
thing
all causal models will be wrong in some
way but if you can generally get the
structure of causality you'll get a
probabilistic model which is very close
to correct and very very usable
so step one describe the joint
distribution using causality
do you guys want to argue about my
causality at all
I welcome arguments there's uh we can
have a debate about many of these things
Will's like you definitely got that
Arrow backwards yeah anyone wanna yes
underground to get the flu from dorms
so you're saying uh undergraduate
actually change you know like you're
getting the flu from dorms therefore
it's the undergrad has a causal push to
change whether or not you have a flu I
agree with that I'm not going to model
it yes
fever makes you more tired yeah is
making you more tired now I'm saying the
flu causes the tiredness
but it might be that the flu causes the
fever and the fever causes the tiredness
that's very reasonable I'm not going to
model it that way but that's very
reasonable yes
um tiredness causes the flu because like
immune systems are
I very much agree with this if you're
tired your immune system goes down and
therefore we think of tiredness as
causing the fever these are all so valid
now if we got into it I think we could
argue for almost links between any two
pairs of variables because there might
be some way that every variable is
causing one another so our job isn't to
get to all the details it's to get the
broad Strokes of causality and so even
though all those arguments are right
these three arrows give us the broad
strokes and I'm going to give you a key
the more arrows you add
the more your probabilistic model will
start to grow exponentially if you have
few arrows you'll grow closer to
linearly and if you have lots of arrows
you'll start to grow exponentially so
I'm pretty reticent to add extra arrows
such a good discussions yes
let's go over the visualization again at
the door distribution you mean of this
one yes so in the
every circle is a random variable
and here I'm using lines to say that I'm
hypothesizing that this random variable
is causing this one's value
oh um we're going to tell you I haven't
told you how to express a joint using
this yet I've just gotten you halfway
through we got on step one but if you
know step two and three we'll know how
to express the joint but you're right
that's your problem right now it's like
I've told you this beautiful picture
drawing technique I have not told you
how to represent a joint which is what
you need
accurate every single
if you could estimate every probability
perfectly
it would get more accurate but the more
arrows I draw the harder it will be for
you to estimate the many more
probabilities you have to estimate and
because of that it might get worse so
it's actually a complicated answer and
often that's kind of how you choose you
might keep adding arrows until your
accuracy starts to degrade there will be
a peak Point there's a whole
conversation about overfitting and
underfitting which we can get into in
221 but that's the broad Strokes of the
conversation
yeah this is so cool I'm so honored to
be able to show you Bayesian networks
for the first time because it's uh I
think one of the cooler pieces of
Technologies in fact the people who
worked on Bayesian networks have like
won all the math Awards
um and and all the big CS like uh
touring Awards because this combination
of mathematics and computer science was
just explosive for the sorts of problems
we could solve
now I have told you how to draw a
picture pretty picture I haven't told
you how to define a joint if you want to
join Define a joint using in Bayesian
Network
here is your next task once you've got
all your arrows
for every single random variable I want
to give you the probability of the
values it can take on
given the assignment to all of its
immediate parents so I've redrawn our
random or our Bayesian Network over here
when I say give me all the probabilities
given its parents let's start with these
two lovely nodes up here they have no
parents in this graph I mean parents by
the graphical term parents right there's
no nodes that have arrows pointing into
it therefore when I say give me the
probability of this node given its
parents I just mean give me the
probability of this node not conditioned
on anything
and I can tell you the probability of a
random person having a flu is 0.1 that's
your job
this note also doesn't have causal
parents so if you want to specify give
me the probability this random variable
taking on the value 1 but not
conditioned on its values of its parents
because there's no parents here so
what's the problem is somebody's a
undergrad walking into Vaden and Vaden
says 80 of the people we see are
undergrads yes
yeah these are I like to think of these
ones at the top they look a lot like
priors but they're all going to be
probabilities
um and yeah actually you can think of
this as like we're going to describe the
joint
and you can kind of think about that
describing your prior belief and then
when you observe things like observist
and undergrad I observe their fever then
all your probabilities will change and
that will give you a posterior so yes
let's call that a prior
so these two do you guys make sense if I
tell you you have to provide the
probability of them giving your parents
these ones are pretty straightforward
this one's a little harder because it's
got a causal parent
I have to give the probability of this
random variable given its parents so I
have to say what's the probably the
fever equals one given flu equals zero
so I have to say if flu is zero what's
the chance of having a fever
I also have to say if flu is one what's
now notice I say for all the possible
assignments to the parents and for each
of them I just do the probably fever
equals one
I might care about the probably that
fever equals zero how could I calculate
the probably a fever equals zero if I
know the probably a fever equals one
you guys feel it in your bones
I hear it murmuring in the air just one
minus this you don't have to specify
fever equals zero because if you specify
fear equals one then if you tell me flu
equals zero I can know probably fever
equals zero by just doing one minus this
how many parents does fever have just
one all the assignments the parents are
assigning a zero to the parent and
assign one to a parent I have given you
the probability of this random variable
given all possible assignments to his
parents oh I haven't actually put
numbers here but I'd have to you know I
don't want to get these different from
what I have on the slides so I'll add
those in a second
either you have a fever or not I mean in
the case that you want to sort of track
on the radius which is be scary uh I
intentionally made everything a
Bernoulli to start with you are right
that we are absolutely going to be able
to expand this model so that fever could
be something like low medium high or
even it could be a real valued number
there's lots of ways you can do this in
fact in the elephant example we had a
Bayesian Network but the thing over here
was weight which was continuous so it's
totally possible to represent something
that's not Bernoulli but let's start
with Bernoulli just because we're doing
a whole bunch of random variables and
that's a nice place to start
good good good question
okay so I'd have to give you two numbers
here so zero point you know what's the
probability that you have a fever given
you don't have the flu Oh that's very
low
and if you do have the flu you might
have a fever but you might not let's say
there's like a 70 chance that you have a
fever Yeah question
most sophisticated model of its like
space complexity Beijing Networks
all right it's like like it like if
we're trying to Model N random variables
yeah uh is the Bayesian Network going to
be the best model with oh whatever space
complexity yeah well so the the you can
imagine like how much space do you have
for representing your probabilities I
think yeah Bayesian Network is one of
the best ways I've ever seen for
representing a joint efficiently it's
like the most compressed you could get
that really comes down to
if you are smart about your causality
though like if as I said if you drew
arrows between everything a Bayesian
Network will degrade to a joint
probability table
okay so here I've given the probably
this round variable and this random
variable and this random variable given
all their parents but I haven't given
the probably this random variable given
all the assignments to its parents it
has two parents both of those parents
can take on two values
and therefore I have to give four
numbers the probability of being tired
give in all these four cases of
assignments to his parents
do you guys see how more arrows can make
things exponential if this had three
parents you would have two to the third
if this had four parents you'd have two
to the four things in this table
so to specify a Bayesian or a Bayesian
Network you first draw your arrows and
then for every node you give the
probability of the node given its
parents wildness coolness powerful
you're going to use this to do some neat
things yes
possibility would phase you oh yeah you
can have like a probability of lots and
lots of ways you can use base theorem
you can use uh the chain rule lots of
good ways you can calculate
probabilities we'll go over that in a
second
okay maybe I'm building you guys up too
slowly because you guys are getting
ahead of me
um
we can talk about this implicit
assumption
now we've defined every random variable
as the probability of itself given its
parents so I'm just writing on the uh
slides what you've got on the board here
I do want to note
that when you are
um making a base net when you write
these causalities you're doing something
very sophisticated that you don't need
to understand but if you did maybe that
would be cool the sophisticated thing
that you're doing is you're starting to
talk about independencies just by
drawing arrows it turns out that if this
is the causal structure flu does not
change your belief in undergraduate
it tells me that if you change your
belief in flu like if I tell you have a
flu my belief that you're an
undergraduate will not change and these
sets of arrows are telling me that
undergraduates independent of flu now as
I said I'm going to leave it to a later
class for you guys to do the complicated
math of figuring out exactly what are
all the independencies assumptions that
are coming from the arrows if I want to
explain where the compression is coming
from the compression that you're going
to get of being able to describe the
joint in a lot fewer numbers is becoming
is because there's implicit
independencies that you get from
causality
basically by saying flu doesn't cause
undergrad and undergrad doesn't cause
flu you are going to gain some
Independence and that allows you to
express things more compactly
one thing must be acyclic you can't have
undergrad cause tired and tired cause
undergrad it will completely break your
whole model if you keep to that rule
then you're just fine
okay now
my claim to you is this
the Bayesian Network has this cool
assumption
if you give me all of these things I can
reconstruct the joint
the way I can reconstruct the joint it
says instead of representing the joint
as this whole honking probability
you don't even have to do chain rule
like if you wanted to try and calculate
this maybe you could represent it you
just from a joint table or you could
have chain rule try and calculate it
Bayes theorem says every time you get a
random variable
if you're trying to get a joint you just
multiply that random variable's value
given its parents what a crazy thing I
think though this makes more sense when
I show you a Bayesian random variable
expressed through code can I show you
that do you guys want to see a joint
distribution of a Bayesian Network this
one expressed in Python
oh man Python's such an expressive thing
so much more expressive than slides can
be sometimes
the WebMD
okay
I have my Bayesian Network and it's
expressed as
a code and particularly if you can write
code that can draw a sample from The
Joint distribution and by draw a sample
I mean like when I run this program
when I run this program
it starts making fake students who
either have the flu or undergraduates
have a fever or are tired if you can
write a program that can sample from the
full joint assignment so you're giving a
value for every single random variable
together jointly
that is an expression of the joint
distribution
for a Bayesian Network
I'm going to start at the top
and I'm going to sample each random
variable
and then if I get deeper in I'm going to
use the values of its parents to update
my belief of the future ones may I Okay
so
first of all we've got to start with
fluent undergraduate those don't have
parents so when I sample them I'm just
going to sample from Bernoulli burn is a
function that I wrote that just either
returns a one or a zero
this returns a one out of 0 with
probability 0.8 and this returns a 1
over 0 with a probability of 0.1
so after I call these two
functions I've decided does my current
fake person
have the flu as my current fake person
in undergraduate
after that I need to choose fever but
when I choose fever I'm going to follow
the Bayes theorem idea and when I choose
fever its probability will be based on
the probability of its parent or the
value of its parents so I've chosen flu
and if flu was chosen to be one then
they have a high chance of having a
fever if flu is chosen to be zero then
they have a low chance of having a fever
so at this point I've expressed a joints
between these three random variables and
I just need to be able to simulate this
last one and then when I simulate it
then I've been I've pulled one sample
from The Joint probability
when I choose tired it's more
complicated because it depends on my
previous choices for undergraduate and
flu and there's four different
combinations for undergraduate and flu
and in each of those four different
combinations I could have a different
probability of whether or not somebody's
tired they don't have to add up to one
for example you know maybe it's
guaranteed you're tired if you're an
undergraduate with the flu
um and you can still have positive
probabilities and they don't add up to
one and that's fine
now at this point I've chosen all my
variables
and as such
I've pulled from the joint
and the claim of the Bayesian Network is
that this is equivalent to if you had a
joint probability table and you were
pulling from a joint using a lookup into
the joint probability table
that was a lot so yes let's talk about
it question
what exactly is happening when you say
choose
I'm sampling so when I say choose fever
I'm going to end up with four variables
every time I make a fake person
they're gonna have flu undergraduate
fever tired they're all Bernoulli's
they'll all be zeros or ones
so when I say choose flu I mean for this
particular sample for this particular
person who I'm making a joint pull from
their probability of the joint
distribution I have to decide if they
have the fever
ah no this is like making a fake person
and I some fake people will have fevers
and some fake people won't
so this is not inference you've got no
information about a person
some yeah yeah so so there's this is a
good good thing to talk about I'm glad
you asked
when you're actually at Vaden and
somebody walks in they will tell you
some things they'll say I have a fever
and I'm an undergraduate
that's an inference question and in
order to solve the inference question we
need a different thing called a joint
and the joint just says what's the
probability of a complete assignment to
the random variable so there are two
things to keep separate the inference
task of somebody's just walked in and
they've told you they have a fever and
they've told you they're an undergrad
that's a separate thing from expressing
what's the probability of these four
random variables taking on any possible
assignment and you need this one to
solve this one we need the joint if we
want to be able to solve the question of
if somebody has a fever and they're an
undergrad what's the probability they've
got the flu
such a good question so what I've got
here is not doing inference
it is sampling from the joint
that leads to more questions yes is
there something you have to do to
calculate the familiar values for tired
or are those given to I actually
couldn't hear you it was a little too
quiet
there's something you have to do to
calculate like the one your weight 0.9
0.1 like the Bernoulli value is required
[Applause]
how do people come up with those numbers
is that what you're wondering yeah like
did you get those numbers
so this is such a great question anytime
we've got probabilistic models there
will be numbers and there's a great
question where do those numbers come
from for example where do these numbers
come from the answer is I made those up
based on a reasonable assumption and
that's one of the places that
probabilities can come from maybe an
expert gives you a pretty reasonable
guess a different way that you can get
those numbers is from data you could say
I've collected data on all the people
who've come into Vaden and eight percent
undergrads I've collected data on all
the people who've come into Vaden and if
I look at all the people who didn't have
the flu and were undergraduates I can
calculate what percentage had uh we're
tired so you could calculate from data
or sometimes experts make them up and
that happens all the time and you should
be wary of them cheeky experts
yes
a conditional table it's like condition
on each of these values I'm going to
tell you they're probably tired
but it has a lot in common with a joint
table
so you know if if
the parents have these values then
what's the probability of tired so
conditional but very similar
and not just
we're nearly returns one of two values
zero one
and it returns a one with the provided
parameter
so when you call Bernoulli this will
give you back either a zero one and the
chance of getting a one is point one
and when you run this function
when you run this hey wait that's not
what I want you at all
python sample
now this is such a programmer's answer
to
how to express a joint I've got a joint
if I can pull a whole human with
assignment to all those four values and
the assignment must be you know
corresponding to the real likelihood of
somebody having this particular
assignment like the chance that I get
not tired not fever not undergrad and
not flu should correspond to How likely
that particular assignment is
and the Bayes net argument is that
because I built a Bayes net
and because I took each variable given
its parents that this is the proper
joint distribution
it is implicitly making some independent
assumptions because causality is not
perfect here they will be wrong but this
is going to be so useful so this is a
wrong model but allow us to go from
exponential space to express a
probabilistic model to linear space to
represent a problem signal so even
though it's going to be a little bit
wrong this is going to be such a good
rep way of representing a joint
boy have I said some complicated things
but you know the the real complicated
thing I've said here is that
I told you how to make a base net it's
simple draw your causality give the
probability of every random variable
given its parents and then my next claim
is that you if you multiply the
probability of every child given its
parents you get the joint and or if you
do a sample where you sample from the
parents and then you sample from the
children given the parents you get a
sample from the joint
and that's really the Bayes theorem
assumption
Bayes Nets tell what we call a
generative story
they say if you have a person with an
assignment to all these four random
variables here this generative way that
you got that you started with these
random variables and then you generated
the children based on the assignments to
the parents I really feel if you could
choose one thing to focus on if you find
this confusing I really do think the
generative story of the code is really
important
it's saying this is how I think the
world works I think if you were to
generate a random person in this world
you would generate in it in this way and
that's why I call it a generative model
we generate the parents then we generate
the children condition on the parents
and the generative model also has the
probabilities of every random variable
given its parents wow so much
okay
are you guys ready for this
I have told you a lot of important
things I've told you about this
beautiful way of expressing a joint but
that is basically useless if you can't
do the cool task of inference and the
cool task of inference says I want to
change my belief uh given that I've seen
some evidence
we're gonna get to inference don't you
want to get to inference because then
it's like then the whole modeling was
worth it
in order to get to inference I first
want you to be able to solve this task
this is a joint assignment it's a
probability but I'm asking for a
particular assignment to all four of my
random variables
and I have a tricky task that's going to
check your understanding
can you tell me the probability of this
particular joint assignment if you're
stuck think about the generative story
what is the probability that flu the
person doesn't have a flu they are an
undergraduate they don't have a fever
and they are tired
can you figure out that probability and
this will be the first step towards that
beautiful beautiful dream that we can do
inference on any graphical model okay
talk about what the person next to you
let's see if we can figure out how to do
this ask me lots of questions I love
this conversation
so
okay
updated
factors
hey Ellie
foreign
oh
okay
this is some heavy math but this is this
is the hardest conceptual part before we
get to inference side I do want to slow
down and I want to answer any questions
you may have
so the Bayesian assumption says that if
you want that whole joint you just take
the probability of every random variable
but if that random variable has causal
farence you have to write it conditioned
on the value of its causal appearance
it's a generative story it's like first
we figure out if somebody's an
undergraduate what's the probability of
somebody's an undergraduate
yeah you guys are gonna help me out
because I can't see the screen so just
yell it out so give me a chance uh
what's probably somebody has a flu
yeah what's the problem they don't have
a flu
okay so this one's 0.9 so the chance
that somebody's an undergraduate and
they don't have a flu
's not saying the test says these two
things multiply by each other that's
what Independence looks like you know
the probability of this particular
assignment being equal to each of them
that's independence
now how about this one the probably that
fever is equal to zero given that flu
equals zero so what's the probably a
fever equals one given that flu equals
zero
okay and then what's the problem that
equals zero
oh fantastic because it's just going to
be one minus the probability that fever
equals one now if undergrads equals one
and flu equals zero what's the
probability that tired equals one
eight zero point eight okay good I was
about to go have to look at my computer
um
the claim is that this joint
distribution you can get by just
multiplying these four probabilities
together and this is saying you know
this is the chance that you see all of
these particular four random variables
at the same time
no matter which assignment to random
variables I gave you you could continue
to use the generative story
and you get a probability of assignment
to all the four random variables jointly
question
this is the probability that papers
okay so let's look at fever's node oh
wait did I get this wrong
oh yeah yeah totally I didn't look at
the screen okay fluid is equal to zero
the problem you have a fever is 0.05 if
you don't have the flu the chance you
have a fever is very very low
so what's the probability that you if
you don't have the flu that you don't
have a fever
0.95 I misheard you guys I heard 0.5 and
so there should have been one minus 0.05
yeah
probability
yes what would it be
a net so let's look
one two three four five six seven eight
we've represented it with eight numbers
instead of 16 numbers it sounds like
you've saved half the numbers but it's
better than that you've gone from
exponential to linear so if there is
more than four random variables you go
from like a billion values in your joint
table to maybe like a hundred
probabilities
it's a number of the number of arrows
it's based on the number of errors it's
based on if you think of the child with
the most arrows that's the one that's
really going to Define it because it
will have 2 to the power of how many
parents it has the child with the most
arrows
yes another question
on a table
I started with the causal story I
started with the nodes with the least
currents
and I took the probably of them given
their non-existent parents and then I
went down from the parents nodes with
the least parents to the nodes with the
most parents so the parent notes to the
children notes
yeah
explain again how you calculate the
probability of being tired um just
because like it has two parents yeah so
the the Bayes net idea is that we're
saying tired is caused by fluid
undergrad so that's why I need to know
if I want to figure out somebody's tired
and if you tell me that
um flu is zero but undergraduates one so
flu is zero but undergraduates won so if
that's the assignment to its parents the
chance that you're tired is 80 because
even though you don't have a flu you're
an undergraduate that makes us sleepy
um and so that's the idea so the base
net is not taking into account whether
or not you have a fever
so there's all these things that is not
taking into account that would have
implicitly been in the joint table
um we're representing it in a much more
compressed faction
because
we know that we're calculating the
probability of all of those four things
we do at the same time exactly
the the idea of the basement is the big
assumption is saying that the joint is
equal to the product of all these
probabilities that's and you can think
of that as a Bayes net assumption
it's true if the causality is perfect
even though the causality is not always
perfect
Oh you mean like you need to someone has
to give you these numbers yes yes yes
absolutely and they come from one or two
places experts or data you could use
data to estimate them by the way if you
have to estimate two to the N numbers
that's hard if you have to estimate like
o of n numbers that's a lot easier from
a data set so you could use a data set
and you could have filled in these
numbers for me
yeah so today if I'm using this uh
Venetian strategy we only have to have
like four terms and the other example we
use a general like Joy probability table
we'd have to have 16 terms what would
those terms look like
you would have a cell in your table for
every assignment you'd have a selling
table for this and you have a cell on
the table for like if you flip this to a
zero for any binary combination of the
random variables you would have a cell
in your table
that's why it's such a disaster total
disaster
causalities implicitly imply
independencies you don't have to know
exactly which ones but that's why we're
getting such reduction
okay one more question then I do need to
continue the conversation
that's why we're using like the hand of
microwave and
yeah
actually the joint is and The Joint says
what's probably of this assignment to
this random variable and this one to
this other one and this one together
that's what the joint's all about and
that's the thing you would need to solve
any probability question
and speaking of which I'm Gonna Bump
this up a notch for you guys
oh man
assume you have for any assignment you
have a way to calculate the joint you
now have the joint my claim is you can
calculate any conditional probability
are you guys ready
what I really want to know is the
inference problem the joint is just like
Scholastic inference is real it solves
people's problems I want to know the
chance that I have a flu
so what's the probability that I have
the flu
given I am not an undergraduate I am in
fact much older though I might look
charmingly young uh I am in fact a
father
so I am an undergraduate
I'm not an undergrad
um am I tired no I'm actually feeling
kind of bouncy uh wait tired equals zero
uh and I don't have a fever
so this should be pretty low but
inference would allow us to answer any
question and my claim for you was
no matter what question you have if you
have a joint you can answer it
may I just explain why
let's first look at this using the
definition of conditional probability if
you use the definition of conditional
probability it would say that this is
equal to
flu equals one my L's are are also a
disaster just like joint probability
tables
ah
l
whatever no I can't use a capital as a
subscript it feels wrong
ah
maybe I do fever whatever that's not
important
so definition conditional probability
says it's the probability of all these
things together divided by the
probability of the thing on the right
hand side do you remember when we first
learned the conditional probability ah
who would have known we would take it to
the max like this that's an e
so this is the definition of conditional
probability
luckily for us this thing is a joint
could you calculate this probability
you could use exactly the same method to
get a joint
could you use exactly the same method to
get this term
no because this term doesn't have flu
but there is a tricky little idea that
you guys might have in your head that
would allow you to get this term where
flu isn't existent
and my key idea for you guys is I say
think about two cases
the case where all these things are true
and somebody has the flu
and the case where all these things are
true and the person doesn't have the flu
how could you get this one using joint
assignments no no I want you guys to
Let's meditate for a moment silence
find your calm
but not your sleepy calm you're like
mindful calm
okay
does anyone see
a way we could do this I'm looking for
somebody yeah somebody hasn't spoken
today yeah
[Music]
yes there's an even easier version of
the laptop
so there's two versions of lab tour
probably one that's got the condition
and one that's got the and
the log told probably that has the and
looks like this I'm going to try and
write this without a sum notation though
my heart really wants to use some
notation I just think it's going to be
easier I'm going to call this whole
thing on the denominator
happy symbol because I don't feel like
writing it again are you guys okay with
that
so we've got ourselves our happy symbol
divided by
and we want to get an expression for
this I'm going to call this whole set of
equations
my
unhappy I don't know why it's unhappy
it's really unhappy but I'm just going
to do that because I don't want to write
it again
so it's the probability that flu equals
one
and all those other random variables
plus the probability that flew equals
zero
and all those other random variables
so all those three are unhappy all those
ones are smiley face so this is the
probably a smiley face oh my God what an
emoji answer I feel like the most
Millennial person right now
so the law of toad probably has two
versions you can say that if you want to
get this thing there's a background
process of whether or not somebody has
flu
and the probability of this is you know
the chance of that assignment in both
the cases where somebody has a flu and
somebody doesn't have the flu
and if you add up those two mutually
exclusive cases you will get the
probability that somebody just has this
assignment of random variables
and now an interesting thing has
happened we have ended up with joint
assignments in this expression I've got
a value for every random variable in
this expression I've got a value for
every random variable in which case I
can use this process to get them
there's a fancy term for this it's
called marginalization
marginalization was easy to think about
when we had two random variables we get
to more random variables it gets a
little bit harder but marginalization
says you know if you want the
probability if I want to write this out
the way I would have liked to using some
notation without smiley faces
I would have said that this is equal to
the probability that U equals zero
uh T equals zero
and fever equals zero is equal to the
sum over all the assignments
to
flu
the probability that flu equals the
current thing in my for Loop and all of
these things so U equals zero tired
equals zero fever equals zero
and those are two different pulls from
The Joint distribution because of
marginalization everything can be solved
as a computation starting from the joint
if somebody gives you the joint you can
calculate your numerator and your
denominator of any inference task
that was a lot
okay
so what have we talked about first I
presented a problem you want to
represent many random variables but you
can't using a joint probability table
you want to be able to do inference but
you need a joint but the joint
probability table is not working then we
gave you Bayesian networks it's a very
compressed way of representing a joint
and once you have Bayesian networks
because you have a way of representing
the joint anytime you have a conditional
probability you can solve it by starting
with the joint and marginalizing out all
the things that you need to
and there you have it we have a full
story we now have Bayesian networks and
they're salt useful for solving any
probability question
oh let's take a pedagogical pause if
people have questions come you can ask
me but let's take two minutes because
that was a whole bunch to cover
yeah why don't you come up to the front
before the Bayesian Network if it's not
Independence in random variables we have
known Independence for a long time if I
told you two events do you guys remember
the day of events ah so humble it was
like the Shire before we went on our big
adventure events okay but in events
world if you want to claim that two
events were independent you could show
it mathematically you could say that the
probability of the two events happening
together is equal to probably of one
event times probably the other event and
that was really the definition of
independence uh though there was a
equivalent version of chain rule
if
two different variable or two events are
not independent they're called dependent
and intuitively
aside from all the mathematics if you
tell me that one of independent one
event's independent another it doesn't
give you information
in the world of random variables the
exact same logic holds because as we
know an assignment to a random variable
is an event
that's an event and that's an event so
Independence is going to look exactly
the same but the one increase in
terminology is that if you claim two
random variables are independent
then this equation has to hold for any
chosen assignment to values so whatever
you choose for a little X and whatever
you choose for little y this equation
must hold if the random variables are
independent so it's a much stronger
claim it's saying knowing anything about
this random variable will tell you
nothing about this other random variable
it's a much deeper claim but at the end
of the day it's the exact same equation
that we've known lived and loved already
so let's go back to our wonderful
friends after all this time still so
good to us dice
let's say you have dice 1 and dice two
are the outcome of two rules and S is
the sum
so the first question I could ask you is
are events that the dice one equals one
and the sum of two dice equals seven
independent
now we looked at this uh earlier and if
you figure out what's the probability
that the first dice equals one well
that's one over six what's the
probability that the sum of two dice
equals seven well it turns out there's
six ways that you can make that happen
out of 36 so that's one over six and
what's the probability that the first
nicest one and the sum is seven
well that means that the first ice was
one second dice is six and there's one
over thirty six ways of doing that we
did this earlier in class
here's another event that we looked at
in class we said if I tell you the first
dice is a one
and the sum is five are those two events
independent and the answer was no if I
told you the first ice was one it
changes your belief that the sum will be
five
because if I told you the first X was
six you know the sum can't be five for
example so if I tell you the first ice
is one all of a sudden you think okay
it's more likely that maybe the two dice
add up to five
seven is the weirdest number like why is
this independent why is knowing the
value of the first ice independent of
the sum being seven
and that's this question and it turns
out it is independent no matter
um
oh so basically these random variables
are not independent but
um this first ice being one and S being
seven the reason it's independent is
if you care about knowing if your sum is
seven no matter what you get on the
first dice there's exactly one thing on
the second dice that leads to the two
being seven anyways
these since this is true and this is not
true it's not true that the two random
variables are independent for the two
random variables to be independent all
of these questions would have to be
check marks for any assignment to D1 and
S stronger claim as I said
okay
and this might lead to the next question
and this is something we'll do if we
just have a little bit of time
but what if you cared about discovering
causality just from data so right now we
have this idea of problems models we
have a way to do inference if you have
problems models what you don't really
have is where do those probabilities
come from and how could I design the
probability Network myself do you guys
want to learn that
okay
what I have for you is a challenge I
have all this data of all these kids in
the UK and they're rating one to five
whether or not they like all these
different genres and there's like 30
different genres so you can imagine a
probabilistic model of 30 different
types of music all together
and we could go and make a base net we
definitely need something like a Bayes
net because 2 to 30 is too large if you
want to talk about joint probabilities
so if you want to say something like was
it probably somebody likes folk given
that like classical any general
inference we'd need a joint
so
we've talked about finding
independencies before in class when we
had the bat DNA problem
um we had data like this and we could
search for independencies and
independencies are going to give you
some hints as to how you want to draw
your causality because if it tells you
know like if you get your data and it
says fluids independent of undergraduate
then great maybe you start to make both
of those your parents
the bat data problem we did you guys
could figure out independencies but I
have a different question for you what
if they weren't booleans what if there
were continuous numbers how could you
find independencies of random variables
that take on not just true or false
values so how do you find independencies
in random variables not just
independencies and events
the bats were events now I've bumped
this up to random variables
and it really starts with this question
here is a picture
of two random variables that look
independent
and here's a picture of two random
variables they're very much not
independent and my question is what are
you curious about what do you wonder and
what do you notice about these two
different pictures
yeah I mean this one looks kind of
splotchy and this one kind of is like
looks a little bit like this diagonally
thing that feels good yeah
I told you
value of a number here
you could kind of have a function that
could take that x value and give you a
guess for the Y value whereas if I tell
you the x value here you're like I don't
know what your y value is your x value
really doesn't tell me that much about
what y value I'd predict
and that's really the idea like in this
picture these things look quite
independent one random variable is not
telling you about the other one and this
one one random variable is very much
telling you about another one
now how about this one
looks kind of like the same picture but
I've shifted things
but my question is semantically is the
same story true
here if I told you about the x value you
know one value of one random variable
could you predict the other one
pretty well yeah you definitely update
your belief if I told you the x value
here would you update your belief on the
Y
it doesn't matter that I shifted it it's
the same thing these ones look quite
independent and that one looks like
there's a little bit more of a
relationship
there is a numerical quantification for
how much two random variables vary
together it's like a beautiful dance you
imagine you have two random variables
and when one goes one way does the other
one also go the same way and one one
goes a different direction does the
other one follow it
this measure of whether or not two
random variables vary together looks
like this
if you take any point you can say how
far is this point deviating from the X's
expectation and how far is it deviating
from the Y's expectation
and you can product those two things
together and if you product those two
things together it has this wonderful
property that if the two points are
deviating in the same direction then
you'll get a positive number like if
they're both negative
if x is below its mean and Y is below
its mean then you'll get a negative
number times a negative number and that
will give you a positive number and
people have decided that this is a
really good way of calculating
numerically a simple statistic to say
are my two random variables being random
together is one of them telling me some
information about the other
now if you took other points like this
point close to the middle if you
calculate this term it would be close to
zero and if you take this point down
here if you calculate this term again it
would be positive because uh the x minus
this expectation is negative and the Y
minus it's an expectation is negative
this term if you calculate in
expectation over your two random
variables gives you something that you
might have heard of before called the
covariance and the covariance says that
like if I find points where both of them
are deviating from their mean in the
same direction then or it'll give me
like some positive product and if I find
points where things are deviating in
negative directions it'll give me a
negative product
if you took all those positive negatives
and averaged it for this plot you get
something close to a zero there's some
positives there's some negatives but
they generally cancel out
but
if you take something
um
I want another picture
okay well
if you took a plot and it just had
points on this diagonal
then all the points would either be
contributing positive values or zero so
in expectation you would get something
positive
and in fact
um
if
X if you take a point and X and Y are
both above their mean you get a positive
number if X and Y are both mean you get
a positive number but if they differ
like if one's above the mean the other
one's below the mean you get a negative
number
the covariance is the expectation of all
these products over the whole random
variables and if you calculate this then
you would get what we call the
covariance it's a measure of how much
two random variables vary together
now that covariance expression is hard
to calculate it turns out it's
numerically equal to this there is a
whole derivation of that which you can
check out in your own time I want to
include it here for complete lists
but I want to give you a sense of how
you would calculate this
the way you would calculate this is
you know the covariance formula at the
end of the day
you could write it like that or you can
write it as this expression this is how
we often calculate it it turns out this
measure of how much these two things
vary together is the expectation of the
product minus the expectation of each
random variable multiplied together
so if we took this data we calculate the
expectation of one random variable we
can calculate the expectation of the
other random variable and then we can
calculate the expectation of the product
to calculate the expectation of product
we just take the products over all the
points and calculate its average
and if you did this you would get a way
of calculating the covariance what I'd
like to show you now is
what it looks like if you look at the
covariance of all of those bats
sorry not the bats the music
this is the covariance for all of the
different music tastes that I told you I
wanted to challenge you to model
if you look at somebody who likes Punk
it has a very high covariance with rock
if you look like somebody who likes a
metal that also has a very high
covariance with rock but it turns out
like if you look at metal or hard rock
it has a very negative covariance with
pop
so if you tell me somebody is very
positive on the metal scale I think
they're more likely to be negative on
the pop scale
it's a simple statistic it's not telling
you a complete causal story but it's
giving you a sense of which random
variables are varying together
my clue for you is this is a little bit
beyond 109 but if you want to come up
with causality from data this is the
first step you take all your random
variables and you look at how much they
co-vary and from this covariance you try
and find structures and you try and have
the art form of Designing how you think
the world works it is an art form but it
will lead to something that is
representable by a computer a Bayesian
Network what a beautiful thing
that was so cool you guys asked such
amazing question I'm really appreciating
you guys thank you for all the hard work
you do come back on Friday we'll
continue this conversation and learn
rejection sampling uh thank you guys and
see you guys later